hey everybody and welcome to the Shan
method this is chris waters here I'm
Sean McGinnis chris has just given me a
terrible idea we're playing far cry 3
right now and Chris you suggested that I
try to race this tiger in a murder
content this is the first challenge of
today's Sean method all right we got a
tiger okay in a cage on a beach yes next
to an we got to red shirt bandit couple
red shirts Tigers are really great at
murdering people with their hand and
mouth knives yeah but you're pretty good
at murdering people with your machete
that's true I want you to shoot that
cage open and then race to see who can
get the most human kills you or the
tiger all right here we go three two one
go go go go go go and the Tigers off to
a great start I think he's already got
that gun yo Shawn been tight oh oh and i
gotta go pee in battle oh [ __ ] we will
be the ultimate Victor get out of here
tiger oh god the stabbing the clawing
got a lot of solid oh no unanticipated
entire dude where'd this guy come from
no go for the bow man a long distant
long distance bow kill this is difficult
this is a challenge I put Italy out like
a hundred meters and they're moving
let's see it Oh beautiful shall we go
nice too bad not bad nicely done that's
pretty good there's a boat coming in
here go for this boat sniper boat boat
Snipes it's gonna be hard cuz uh oh oh
the best way to hunt sharks is with a
grenade right like a grenade launcher a
grenade launcher or a grenade a single
grenade I mean I feel like because you
don't want to tip the odds too much in
your favor so I feel like a grin like
straight-up regular grenades are
probably the best way to deal
mm-hmm you need to bait yourself he use
myself as bait I go thrash around out
there I real good idea where are those
sharks at sharkys see you shirts so
there's a shark all right here we go
that shark was sniffing around oh no
didn't quite get on it here we go that
was that looks like a good girl yeah
right in the underbelly there we go
we're feasting on shark meat tonight i
will put your skin in my wet meat sack
your for wet meat sack from which meat
does not float out just when you're
carrying it around yeah I want to see it
ah nice oh my god they're just good old
boy yeah he just lowdown I want to see
you I want to see the grenade exploded
above the water and kill the shark in
the water okay that timing could be a
little bit trickier yes that's it that's
a tough throw you're not even making it
halfway there go go go go go ah that's
before I think our work here up I'm not
gonna let him get away though this is
what is this back to the deeps from
whence you came shark all right let's
skype a boat should I snipe this boat I
feel like you can snipe these vehicles
in like their engine blocks and they
just get so no there's a boat fire fire
let's see these guys don't even realize
what's going to those guys are friendly
oh no oh no he's burning dog get out oh
no captain goes down with the ship I
want to I want another long-range long
rainbow yeah should i mix it up what do
you what he thinking food
this is hard to aim because of the fire
oh they didn't see you though these guys
are a little spinner like why did that
grass just catch on fire oh my goodness
it's right near my pants I have I have
the good sense to skedaddle across the
road if kind of seeing you now oh yeah
he's setting that grass on fire oh yeah
said his Molotov oh I'll eat it Molotov
just goes to show if you're gonna carry
molotovs on your belt loop you know
you're gonna have a bad time you're
gonna have a bad time hard to tell nope
they're bad guys hey bad guys you want
to come over this way oh man oh come on
guys this is totally gonna go well for
you and not at all terribly don't worry
guys pay no attention to the man holding
the detonator and the large packet of
explosive on run right by that truck
come on I think he's dead excessive I
think he might be text I think those two
whoa you think that's too much rid of
one guy what are all those dogs do it Oh
dog fight oh it's a dog party you got to
burn all those dogs on fire no oh come
on that was a classic Molotov situation
you're right now you just have a pile of
dogs you have to skin for all their dog
no they're still it's alive are they
dead Wow usually where six dogs they
killed a lot of dogs oh no no I know
note Oh what am I done but they're good
none we're gonna go through this sweet
ass was gonna end well Oh God what that
wasn't a waterfall that I can drive
through that's [ __ ] ah come on drive
it up the waterfall
the juice is gonna work though here we
go oh god I'm gonna buy oh yeah yeah
it's ok it's good no it's good it's good
it's good it's ok we're good don't even
sweat it bro don't worry about it we're
gonna do that again more jet ski jumping
here we go Oh gonna make it over oh oh
grinding to a halt push it this is one
of the features i really like about this
game and perfect now we wait oh here
they come oh there there there yeah oh
nice Oh eat it Oh delightful Oh where'd
they go where their dead bodies honey
the teabag them oh it's the grass okay
all right let's get a you're not going
for the flaming teabag know that the
piping hot tea bag that let's find on
being looked at by something right now
let's lines is showing at you how do you
assume that I will be able to find
sharks and drive onto them with my
pickle I don't know but I don't think
yep okay it's fine yep you're okay
weirs on the Sharks Chris go Laila bout
in the water I don't know if you jump oh
there's a meet your boat that's yeah I'm
gonna Park it here I don't want any
sharks to steal it yeah I think swimming
and probably the best way to find a
shark you got to get into their mindset
yeah you know I gotta be one would get a
shard Inc like a shark in order to
attract a shark perhaps a shark mating
call it's very alluring to sharks you
and I whoa here we go here we go see oh
man okay friend all right good good i'm
leaving now and taste of blood in the
water wow you've got a car try not to
lose it as we go let's try not to get
killed look there's a shark ernest
coming for you Sharky oh ah free mature
too enthusiastic oh there's a target all
right there it is here's comes on the
right ready come go go go punch it come
on shark ah oh [ __ ] sure you're gonna
drown a dead shark alright honky tonk
what do you say alright I think we're
good you go out of the bank where should
we go out with a bang obviously all
right here we go um I said earlier that
how would repent for all my sins he
particularly against the civilians who
meant me no harm I feel like that's the
only way to do it it is thank you for
watching folks this is the Shan method
it's on every Wednesday 11p a.m. pacific
I'm Chris waters at Shawn McGinnis so
long